hey we're gonna place you running here
anyhow welcome it down to mr. Menton Oh
New Zealand fish I'm Steve Adubato Willy
Wonka and the Chocolate Factory is a
classic children's film were a bipolar
sociopath gives away his candy Empire to
a boy with no prior business experience
who he's only known for a few hours it's
a wonderful film full of pure
imagination but after watching it again
we have some questions I'm sorry but all
questions must be submitted in writing
who is this creepy guy outside the
factory what's with his cart of knives
and why don't we ever see him again
what is a wanker er is it an insult if
so why aren't these kids offended by it
you look like you were born to be a
wanker up whose fishface is he Mike's
friend how did he get that nickname does
he like it or his Mike being a jerk if
so why are they friends
if Grandpa Joe's been bedridden for 20
years why aren't his legs weaker and
when did he and Charlie have time to
work out this choreography
did mr. gloop ever digest that
microphone is that even possible
did it hurt coming out the other end why
are none of the parents alarmed that a
strange man with a face scars sneaking
around and trying to touch their
children what's going on here
did these two secret love birds meet up
afterwards is there an oompa loompa
Union do they get hazard pay and when
did they have time to work out this
choreography if you are wise you listen
to me is the LSD fairy the only way to
get to the inventing room what if the
bathrooms down the hall do you have to
take it every time you have to go is it
always this freaky or do you get used to
it after a while
is this what turned Wonka into a wacko
wait a minute what's all that small
print there at the bottom did the other
children's parents sue Wonka after the
tour they didn't sign that waiver only
their kids did is assault not considered
assault when it's whimsical
hell please Bert and finally why doesn't
a magical candy land like this exist yet
what of our candy makers been doing for
the past 40 years where are their
priorities you get nothing
you lose good day sir
I said good day